Drake and Rihanna we have been trying to
ship these two forever and it's finally
happened we have not had a love saga
this good since Ross and Rachel and if
you don't believe me let me catch you up
Drake he first laid eyes on his Barbados
beauty in 2005 where she was shooting
her first music video ever for pwned a
replay she shot it in his hometown of
Toronto fast forward in two thousand
nine months after all that Chris Brown
drama when Drake and RiRi were
reportedly spotted out making out at a
bowling alley she do still there were no
real sparks no real romance Drake was
just that kid from Degrassi trying to
make it in wrapp in fact he actually
rapped about this date in his track
fireworks now let me remind you 2009
Drake is 22 and according to his VMA
speech that's when he first fell in love
with Rihanna then in June 2010 Drake
opened up to the New York Times about
being played by Rihanna
but then in November that same year we
got what's your name oh what's my name
[Music]
it's their first collaboration together
and the first of many Rihanna and Drake
bump and grind the chemistry in this
video is next-level and it's like come
on just do it already
still they weren't a real couple just
yet and drink once again opened up to L
about how I felt bird by reread you
sensitive since mistake by 2012 they hit
us with another amazing collab this time
the heartbreaking track take care for
you and here's where things get real
interesting June 2012 Drake reportedly
gets in a bar brawl with Rihanna's ex
Chris Brown June 2013 Drake tells GQ
that love triangle was embarrassing I
mean this is not an episode of the hills
September 2013 Drake opens up to Ellen
queen of daytime in my personal style
inspiration and says that RiRi is a
great girl and they had their moment the
next couple years are just straight-up
rumors
they're dating they're not dating
hooking up they're just friends quit
playing games with my heart you guys and
that brings us to present times and what
do you know they're bad professionally
remember that bumpin and grindin I
mentioned earlier look no further than
the work video
yeah okay I mean come on they've been
pretty much a toss at the hip appearing
at multiple live appearances ever since
then there's of course the recent VMAs
and all the PDA which brings us up to
speed when a source told et that Drake
and Rihanna are definitely a couple and
let's be real things are just heating up
for dreary I just have one piece of
advice for drink like you mentioned
Rihanna has not changed since day one
she is strong years counting badass so
all I'm telling you is be careful
protect your heart but what do you guys
think of the summer's sexiest couple are
you all about it or are you anti tree
read should we come up with another
couples name let us know in the comments
section below or tweet me at D direct oh
and be sure to subscribe to et's youtube
channel because we are following their
every